ella kissy debra was a keen swimmer
dancer and cyclist
by the age of nine she had the reading
age of a teenager but she never made it
to her 10th birthday
over a three-year period she suffered
numerous seizures going into hospital 27
times with breathing problems an inquest
in 2014 found
ella died of acute respiratory failure
after a severe asthma attack
but that was quashed when new evidence
emerged about local air pollution
her mother wants air pollution recorded
as the cause of death
something that's never happened before
in the uk for the first six years of her
life
there is no warning ever of how
everything was going to end hopefully
from this case we will learn a lot more
about air pollution and the impact
on health and governments everywhere
will take action
so no children will have to go through
what my late daughter went through
the new inquest is also considering what
steps were taken to reduce air pollution
and to inform the public
experts say pollution levels at a
monitoring station here in catford near
ella's home
consistently exceeded legal limits in
the years up to her death
most of ella's half-hour walk to school
was along this highly congested road
two years after she died an expert
report concluded
there was a direct link between her
condition
and levels of nitrogen dioxide and
airborne particles in this area
the inquest could set a precedent
helping people
hold local and central government to
account for the air they breathe
rosamund kisidebra was never told about
the risks of air pollution to her
daughter
but clean air campaigners say there's
now plenty of evidence it's cutting
short thousands of lives across the uk
it causes and makes worse a whole host
of diseases
from asthma to heart attacks to
cardiovascular disease to dementia
and we know that it impacts the most
vulnerable the hardest as well so that's
children
older people and also those on lower
incomes
the local authority where rosamund lives
has admitted it should have treated
pollution levels as a public health
emergency
she's hoping the inquest into ella's
death can make everybody think about its
impact
and take action to save lives nadine
barber al jazeera
london